[Applause]
you're
[Applause]
clearly such a strong person but why did
you decide to join the military in the
first place oh that's a funny story um
i decided to join the military because i
have a
cousin
she was in the air force now you hear me
i said she
she was in the air force she was my role
model
i saw her in the uniform
i saw her going places all over and it
looked so glamorous and it looked like
you know in my eyes that
the military was the place to be and she
looked not just
she looked so stupid she looked
important
and i wanted to be like that
so
that's one of the reasons why i joined
once you got in it and you saw how it
really functioned and you got onto the
inside and you weren't just looking at
the outside how did you
find that women were treated so
i love the military i want to say that
first
i love the united states military but
actually being in um
we as women we go to the front line we
are in war
and we're not recognized there was times
in the beginning
when i first joined
i didn't even get a chance to do the job
that i was trained for
we don't even get recognized
outside the military we do every single
job every single job that the military
offers we do
is it true that you had an interesting
interaction with a veteran after you
returned home so not just on the front
lines but back at home oh yes
um my wife and i we were we pulled up to
the gas station and i have disabled
veteran plates
i have a wounded warrior sticker in my
front window
obviously a veteran looking vehicle
and um a gentleman was behind me
pumping gas
and he finished pumping his gas and
pulled in front
and he came to salute me and said um
you know make sure you tell your husband
that i said thank him for his service
in turn i turned to him
and i told him you know what thank you
for your service
and i'm the veteran
and what was his reaction in that moment
i think he was shocked and embarrassed
and he just drove off
i first got to know about wounded
warrior about 10 years ago
a friend of mine is a big participator
and it brought the project to my
attention
and
when i
see
the way your life has transformed with
them
this is so much more than a topical
association
it's like
they it seemed like they did
give you a door that you walked through
and on the other side of that door was a
life waiting for you
let me tell you
i can't do anything but when i think of
wounded warrior project
a smile
because um
just like you said wounded warrior
project is not just an organization yes
this is an organization that
empowers
women this organization
literally gave me my life back it didn't
give me my life back it actually
boosted and kicked forward
my life
um without wounded warrior project i
probably wouldn't be here
um when the work project gave me a
community
gave me family
when you're in the military
you gain a family
and sometimes being injured and getting
out of the military you kind of lose
those connections lose that family
and every single event i've ever been on
with the warrior project it's like going
to a family reunion and i have that
family again i have those connections it
gives you that camaraderie and
without wounded warrior project i know
myself and a lot of others wouldn't be
here
well i'm so glad that you are here donna
and
on international women's day
your fierceness your strength your life
choices your life attitude choosing to
go and serve and protect choosing to be
on a high road when every other option
seems probably easier
you're such an inspiration thank you and
i'm so glad to meet you and hear your
story thank you donna thank you and to
learn more about how wounded warrior
project is helping lift up female
veterans visit wounded
woundedwarriorproject.org forward slash
empower women vets
thank you donna
[Music]